FOEAODAYA MOVET PRESIDENT
D ANNEX THOSE JUST PREOR
TERRIE
MEANTIME, PUTIN INITIATED
RVISTSTEAGAIN, HE THREATENEDAINT
ICNI
O HAVE YOUINSIGHT.
RES WEEKYOUR
PPE NS
T THEYAPAND TORTURS
TU S OL
HEARD AT>> WELL, SISJUST P
OK.
THEY'VHI
THEY UNDERSTAND R NO
TOE ENDIERS.
HEAROF THAT
AND 70 WERE EXPECTED TO BEHE R,W
T PROMISE.T IS
GENERAL, IAN ABOUT
SECURITYEROL NUCLEARAPONS HEREC
P CLOSER TO A NUKR
ATOES THE WEST HAVE
P THAT? PBAY THE
IMON IS TO RESOLVED
AND SEND A CLE TO VL PIN
AS J DURG E CRLL NOT S SAT A O .
>> BETEN THRTS
G  3HE WHAT DOES IT TELL YOUE CN
RETE
MOVES.
PAR VLADIMIR  O
PUTIN TOP TH  LONASSEES IT'
NECESSY.
MAY BE AC .ITLYT SEEM
THID HATS TO SOON BECAUSE THEYG
HOSEERVISTS,
ECTHMANPOWER MIG ROM THE UKRAIN
COUNTEROEN
G
SEE TOO MUCH HAPN NOW
CA BTHE BALE.ERVTS
VE TO YOU HAVE TO BRG EM
YOU  TO GET THEM TTHE LD, I
>> NOWTHERSOE ECAPPAREPUN MSDIC
ANLIRYADE GH. OF ALL,TICIANS ANO
WE SAW TT WITH
WOD .
T  ALSO SAW THAT WITH
PRESIDENT JOHNSON DURING THEBOI6
THE INDIVIDUAL SOLDIER ETTN WORS
ANHERE SOME ENCE INTERCEPTSOMETH
LAMEG NS
MOSCOWG.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE  T TLSO
DON'KN AOLERN WAR WHCH ERS.
BUT THE FAEMNS PNTHE
NUMBERWE, USINILE SCRER  AE WAR.